vous n'êtes pas amoureuse en ce moment
hein
ah bon déjà
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu savais que l'Ukraine avait
la bombe atomique elle est là voilà je
la trouve plus jolie encore plus jolie
de plus en plus jolie moi ça me donne
envie de présenter tout le monde en
parle en Ukraine quand je vous vois vous
voulez que je raconte votre vie oui
j'attends de ça
en 1979
dans un milieu très pauvre vous dites
j'avais rien à bouffer donc c'est même
pas les HLM du avant là il y avait rien
à bouffer vraiment c'était
il y avait des fois du pain sec
des patates moi j'ai pas du caviar pas
du caviar vocation précoce vous avez su
que vous vouliez être actrice le jour
vous avez vu une troupe dans votre école
répétée mais vous étiez trop petites oui
j'étais trop jeune la maîtresse a pas
voulu oui elle a pas voulu parce que
elle s'occupe pas s'occupait pas des
enfants de 10 ans voilà et en fait vous
n'écoutez pas ça à l'âge de 13 ans vous
quittez l'Ukraine et vous en stop
le crâne je suis parti à Moscou quand
j'avais 15 ans
donc vous quittez l'Ukraine à l'âge de
15 ans je dirais
l'escroc direction Moscou vous vous êtes
repéré dans le métro par un talent scout
ça s'est passé comment ah d'accord alors
oui c'est vrai c'était très grave
à l'âge de 13 ans je suis allé en
vacances donc vous quittez l'Ukraine
pour aller en vacances à Moscou une
semaine une semaine une semaine bien
et donc à Moscou vous êtes repéré dans
la banlieue de Moscou
dans le centre dans le métro dans le
métro de Moscou vous êtes repéré
vous êtes repérés par un telen scout et
voilà qui me propose de
d'être mannequin et voilà et voilà c'est
comme ça que vous débutez dans la
carrière de top model c'est incroyable
comme quoi faut prendre le métro pour
faire les couvertures
la première fois que je voyais un métro
le métro les petits l'escaliers qui
bougent et vous devenez top model
international pour les plus grandes
marques alors aujourd'hui ça continue
parce que vous êtes la vedette d'un film
qui s'appelle l'annulaire de Diane
Bertrand avec Marc barbe et vous alors
le coup de bol en fait c'est d'avoir été
choisi alors que la réalisatrice ne
voulait pas de mannequin la directrice
de casting elle a insisté que Diane me
voir parce qu'il me connaissait voilà et
on a fait des essais et puis ça a marché
le film s'appelle l'annulaire c'est le
deuxième long métrage de Diane Bertrand
qui est adapté du roman de Yoko Ogawa
alors c'est marrant ce film parce que
tout a l'air réel et pourtant c'est très
étrange c'est c'est ça frôle le
fantastique c'est toujours comme ça
à la limite c'est filmé de manière très
esthétisante il la musique très belle de
best Gibson qui était la chanteuse de
Portishead
alors c'est un film sur le désir sur le
deuil
assez étrange quand même non c'est un
film sur l'amour comme c'est la première
fois qu'on se voit
on va faire une interview première fois
[Musique]
alors votre premier souvenir
ma grand-mère qui m'apporte un verre de
lait avec des gâteaux au lit deux
gâteaux
votre premier choc
quand une voiture m'a renversé
tout le temps
votre premier péché
notre premier coup de foudre
heureusement que tu fais pas cette
émission avec moi comment il faisait
cette émission avec moi et heureusement
que tu n'es plus la team casses tous mes
coups il est jaloux parce que je l'ai
embrasser sur la bouche et maintenant je
m'intéresse à quelqu'un
le premier baiser sur la bouche sans la
langue c'était au vous savez les comment
s'appelle les campagnes
mais j'étais dans un j'avais dit avoir
10 ans 10 ans
c'était là-bas et le premier baiser avec
la langue
ce garçon de la mon cours de danse le
premier flirt poussé avec un garçon
flirt poussé enfin vous appreniez les
termes le flirt pousser alors qu'est-ce
que c'est de faire pousser explique lui
c'était toujours
le même votre première expérience
homosexuel
c'est un secret je dis pas
première fois à trois
première fois 4
je regardais premier chagrin d'amour
ouais peut-être j'avais 15 ans
[Rires]
s
un peu froides avec tout ça vous avez
pas l'air de vraiment vous passionner
je vous trouve très
scorpion
quand même sentimental
que ça le gars finalement peut-être de
temps en temps déjà
[Rires]
[Musique]
mes amis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention
vous devez porter un grand chapeau
pendant 10 minutes
ah oui ben voilà je porte un chapeau et
voilà vous allez porter un chapeau tu
vas bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu